the bulk of canvas interaction that
grits uses is through rendering images
to the canvas in order to draw an image
to the canvas we first have to load it
in order to load an image we need to
create a new image object which in
JavaScript is comprised of three steps
number one is we need to declare the
image object number two is we need to
define its onload function then number
three we need to set the image dot
source attribute it's worth noting that
as soon as the source property for this
image is set to a value JavaScript will
kick off a load function because of this
we need to specify the callback function
first before setting the source
attribute otherwise the image will load
the data and we won't get a callback
received now let's take a look at this
code here is the URL of the image that
we'd like you to load what we want you
to do is create a new image object
following the steps we just mentioned
and set the onload function and source
properties for that image described in
the code make sure that your onload
function is assigned to this own image
load down here which will actually print
out some nice little message to the
console.log letting you know that things
have loaded properly if you're confused
about whether or not your image is
loading don't forget to check out
Chrome's developer tools on the network
tab which will list whether or not the
image has been loaded and how long it
took to do it